[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je m'appelle
Elise renoi Eden je suis avocate au
barreau de Paris et je suis également
présidente bénévoles de l'association
anticorruption anticorps
contre la corruption en déposant des
plantes contre des élus soupçonnées de
corruption le travail qu'on fait il est
essentiel il est nécessaire parce que en
France le procureur de la République qui
est chargé
de poursuivre les personnes qui sont
soupçonnées d'avoir commis des
infractions pénales peut se retrouver en
difficulté lorsqu'il s'agit d'attaquer
le pouvoir ou des cercles proches du
pouvoir
pourquoi parce que l'évolution de la
carrière d'un procureur dépend du
ministère de la Justice qui peut du coup
compromettre sa carrière et c'est là
qu'anticorps intervient le travail que
l'on fait nous c'est d'aller chercher un
dossier sur le bureau du procureur de la
République pour l'amener sur le bureau
d'un juge d'instruction qui lui est
constitutionnellement indépendant on le
fait pour défendre un principe qui est
fondamental dans un état de droit qui
est le principe d'égalité dont la loi on
le fait pour combattre l'impunité de
certains certaines classes politiques et
pour démontrer aux citoyens qu'il y a
pas de super élu et que personne n'est
au-dessus des lois
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
un agrément associatif qui nous permet
de faire ça et nous permet de saisir un
juge d'instruction cet agrément il est
souvent en danger il est pas évident à
obtenir on a eu beaucoup de difficultés
en 2021 on est de nouveau en difficulté
parce que manifestement l'action de
l'association anticorps déranger
une certaine classe politique
le travail que l'on fait nous c'est
d'étudier les dossiers et de chercher à
comprendre si les comportements qui sont
mis en exergue dans ces dossiers
constitue des infractions pénales on
travaille sur plusieurs infractions
pénales d'abord la corruption la
corruption ça consiste pour un élu à
accepter un avantage en contrepartie de
faire ou de ne pas faire quelque chose
on travaille sur le trafic d'influence
le trafic d'influence c'est le fait
d'accepter un avantage également mais
cette fois-ci pour utiliser son
influence pour qu'une autre personne
fasse ne fasse pas quelque chose on
travaille sur la prise illégale
d'intérêt la prise légale d'intérêt ça
consiste à laisser un intérêt personnel
interférer dans la décision publique que
l'on est chargé de prendre
[Musique]
l'équilibre entre la vie personnelle
entre la vie professionnelle avec tous
ces événements inexorables qui viennent
perturber cet équilibre et moi j'ai ma
vie personnelle bien heureusement j'ai
ma vie professionnelle mon cabinet
d'avocat et j'ai ma vie militante qui
représente quasiment un temps plein
donc c'est un trio infernal et c'est
très difficile déjà de trouver de
l'équilibre avec cette villa et c'est
encore plus difficile lorsque un de ces
événements qu'on pouvait pas prévoir
intervient vient perturber cet équilibre
qui est déjà qui est déjà fragile donc
je suis en permanence débordée en
permanence en déséquilibre mais ce que
j'avais envie de vous dire c'est que
paradoxalement cette vie militante là
elle m'apporte énormément et elle
m'apporte de l'équilibre
je crois que je serai très malheureuse
si j'avais pas anticorps parce que je me
sentirais vraiment démuni face à ce que
je comprends des dysfonctionnements
notre société et il y a beaucoup de
combats à mener il faut les mener c'est
bien c'est bien et important de les
mener mais moi si j'ai choisi ce combat
là le combat contre la corruption c'est
parce que je considère que c'est un
combat racine que c'est un combat qui
permet aux autres combats de prospérer
je pense que le combat pour le climat
par exemple il ne pourra être victorieux
que si on arrive à réduire le lobbying à
une activité de simple plaidoyer et si
on arrive à encadrer davantage les
allers-retours publics privés je pense
que les combats pour le mal logement
pour la malbouffe pour la protection des
personnes vulnérables
c'est qu'on Bala ne seront également
victorieux que si on arrive à s'assurer
que c'est l'intérêt général qui est au
centre de la décision publique et ça
c'est le combat d'anticorps
la corruption le coût de la corruption a
été chiffré par le Parlement européen en
2016 à 120 milliards d'euros par an
uniquement en France
c'est un chiffre évidemment phénoménal
mais pire que ça les statistiques
récentes vous disent que les infractions
politiques et financières ont augmenté
de 28% entre 2016 et 2021
ce chiffre-là cet argent là c'est 120
milliards c'est une richesse monumentale
qui est confisquée aux États et donc aux
citoyens c'est deux fois le budget
annuel de l'éducation nationale qui est
le plus gros budget ministériel en
France
c'est un chiffre qui rend les enjeux de
la réforme de la retraite ridicule et
qui aurait pu éviter la crise sociale
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui en
France c'est un chiffre qui est manière
aussi pragmatique signifie quelque chose
le coût de construction d'un hôpital de
30 000 mètres carrés aujourd'hui en
France c'est 105 millions d'euros
ça veut dire que chaque année on
pourrait financer
la construction de 1142 hôpitaux
voilà l'impact de la corruption ça fait
des années qu'on écoute la détresse de
nos de nos soignants et que et qu'on est
solidaire certaines manières moi je
voulais vous dire qu'en fait
probablement une des plus manières les
plus efficaces de les aider c'est de
lutter contre la corruption alors
évidemment on peut pas éradiquer
totalement la corruption c'est
impossible ça veut dire que c'est 120
milliards on pourra jamais les récupérer
les réinsérer dans les finances
publiques mais on peut se battre en tant
que citoyen on peut se battre on peut se
battre contre les abus de pouvoir on
peut se battre contre les détournements
d'argent public on peut se battre contre
la captation de la décision publique et
c'est essentiel de le faire parce que je
suis persuadée que la corruption
provoque l'effondrement des
civilisations et je suis venue pour vous
parler de ce sujet là
il y a quelque chose de d'assez
surprenant avec la corruption c'est que
en tant que citoyen on se considère
rarement comme victime de la corruption
c'est un espèce de préjudice diffuse
dans la société qu'on ressent pas
forcément personnellement pourtant on
est tous victimes de la corruption on
est victime de la corruption déjà parce
que la corruption elle a un coût et que
ce coût finalement on le finance on le
compense en payant des impôts en descend
des contribuables en étant tout
simplement des consommateurs en payant
en payant la TVA donc la corruption a
directement un coût sur nos vies
et cet argent public c'est cet argent
public qui va utiliser par exemple pour
donner des marchés publics à des prix
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
concurrence à des proches parce qu'on
veut les enrichir à des sociétés parce
qu'elles vont embaucher le neveu la
nièce d'un tel le cousin ou alors parce
que elles ont promis un renvoi
d'ascenseur lorsqu'on sera passé du
public au privé
on est victime aussi parce que cet
argent il va pas où il doit aller cet
argent il devrait notamment aller dans
les services publics et il y a une idée
assez répandue en France que il y a trop
de fonctionnaires dans ce pays mais ça
c'est parfaitement faux il y a pas assez
de fonctionnaires en France il y a pas
assez d'agents publics au manque de tout
absolument partout on manque de
personnes à l'hôpital on en manque
drastiquement dans la justice on en
manque dans l'aide à l'enfance dans
l'aide aux personnes âgée aux personnes
handicapées pour construire des routes
pour construire des collèges des lycées
on en manque absolument partout on est
aussi victime à cause de la qualité de
ce service public parce que pour vous
donner un exemple quand un maire
embauche sa soeur comme agent municipale
ils ne l'embauche pas parce que c'est la
personne la plus compétente pour remplir
ses missions elle est recrutée à cause
du lien privilégié qu'elle détient avec
la personne que nous avons chargé de
prendre une décision
et peut-être que cette personne va mal
travailler peut-être qu'elle va pas
travailler du tout peut-être qu'elle va
pas travailler et qui lui arrivera
absolument rien
donc voilà on se demande toujours
comment on fait pour arriver à ce
chiffre qui est monumental de 120
milliards d'euros et c'est comme ça
qu'on y arrive on y arrive à force de
bien public vendu à ville prix à des
proches à force de marcher public
truqués à force d'épouse assistante
parlementaires qui ne travaille pas
et tous ces phénomènes là
anticorps on est près de 7000 citoyens
et on considère que cette situation là
elle est parfaitement inacceptable on
considère que c'est la démocratie qui
trinque à chaque fois que l'intérêt
général n'est pas au centre de la
décision publique depuis 20 ans il y a
une accumulation une accumulation
intolérante intolérable de scandales
politiques aux financiers et finalement
nous en tant que citoyen c'est quasiment
habitué anticorps qu'on dit c'est que il
faut pas s'habituer il faut pas
s'habituer à cette situation et il faut
il faut résister on dit que c'est 60 000
euros de subventions donnés par la
mairie c'est 2,5 millions de projets
subventions donnés par un ministère ces
embauches de complaisance ces marchés
publics truqué ils sont la cause
d'une crise démocratique qui est majeure
d'ailleurs vous avez des chiffres que
nous donne le cevipov qui nous disent
qu'aujourd'hui
76% des Français considèrent le
personnel politique plutôt corrompu
il y a encore des élus quand je discute
avec eux qui me disent mais si les gens
vont pas voter c'est parce qu'ils sont
paresseux dimanche c'est quand même une
situation de déni extrême à mon sens si
les personnes n'ont pas voter c'est
parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas dans la vie
politique l'exemplarité qu'ils appellent
de leurs vœux donc il faut changer ça il
faut se battre pour redonner du sens au
service public il faut se battre pour
donner du sens aux valeurs démocratiques
parce que si on fait pas ça c'est notre
civilisation qui s'effondre puisqu'elle
est basée sur un régime de démocratie
représentative qui implique que les
citoyens aient confiance dans leur
représentants politiques
anticorps
dans le monde de la lutte anticorruption
par nos procès on est devenu un acteur
majeur de la lutte contre la corruption
on a porté plainte dans 159 dossiers je
vous le disais
mais on continue à dire et c'est très
important pour nous que tous les élus
sont pas pourris d'abord ces
factuellement vrai il y a énormément
d'élus qui ont l'éthique Chevilly au
corps et qui se battent au quotidien
dans des conditions difficiles pour
défendre l'exemplarité et en plus de ça
le discours tous pourris qui est un
discours profondément populiste
n'aidera jamais la démocratie c'est pas
ça qu'il faut faire il faut défendre
l'exemplarité
je sais pas seulement venue vous
déprimer je suis aussi venue vous
transmettre de l'énergie en vous disant
que ce combat il est essentiel il est
important il est possible et il est même
parfois efficace
je suis venue vous dire que il faut
qu'on grandisse en tant que citoyen il
faut arrêter d'attendre l'homme
providentiel qui va tout d'un coup
changer la situation c'est pas de ça
dans notre société a besoin notre
société elle a besoin de contre-pouvoir
et elle a besoin de contrôle
et anticorps c'est ça qu'on fait on est
d'un contre-pouvoir et on contrôle
l'action de nos élus et vous pouvez
résister à nos côtés si vous le voulez
en lançant l'alerte lorsque vous êtes
témoin de dysfonctionnement de la
société
vous pouvez nous aider à réunir des
preuves dans les dossiers vous pouvez
nous aider à informer à communiquer vous
pouvez vous battre en diffusant une
culture de l'éthique via les réseaux
sociaux via les syndicats via les
entreprises il y a les partis politiques
au lycée au collège partout
et je voulais vous dire aussi que
Anticor est très connu parce que on
combat la corruption mais en fait on se
bat aussi pour le rétablissement de
l'éthique en politique et c'est aussi
très important on a une cérémonie
annuelle qui s'appelle la cérémonie de
remise des prix éthiques ou on remet des
Mariannes à des élus à des journalistes
à des chercheurs à des artistes qui ont
contribué
au combat pour l'éthique et je vais
terminer on vous dire en vous disant que
j'ai l'espoir secret que un jour je
pourrais remettre un prix éthique à l'un
de vous
[Applaudissements]